[Music]
tom holland is one of the biggest young
stars in hollywood today the 25 year old
actor was catapulted into international
stardom when he first suited up a
spider-man in 2016's captain america
civil war joining the marvel cinematic
universe is a sure-fire way to join the
hollywood a-list and holland was no
exception
all right kid
you're an avenger now
since becoming an avenger the british
actor has had the chance to show off his
acting chops in various non-superhero
films including the kriti war drama
cherry this 2021 flag proved to be
holland's biggest departure from the
wholesome nurse of the mcu it follows a
young former soldier who struggles with
ptsd after returning home from fighting
in iraq playing such a troubled and
nuanced character was quite the
challenge for holland too who has since
revealed just how much of a told the
film took on his health in an interview
with british gq tom holland revealed the
health difficulties he faced filming
cherry production began with the scenes
depicting holland's character in the
thrones of addiction and his appearance
had to reflect that revealing that his
trainer told him to eat only 500
calories a day and run 10 miles holland
remembered i lost around 27 pounds by
running in a bin bag every day while
this would be a difficult turn for any
actor it was made worse by the need to
bulk back up again for his scenes as an
army medic holland shared it was brutal
i got very sick actually and it's
changed my relationship with food
completely the experience was so
grueling that holland has sworn off
doing anything similar in the future in
the same interview with gq he said i
think i would find it very difficult to
find a role that would warrant that sort
of abuse on my body again holland
elaborated this role took me to some of
the darkest places i've ever been
emotionally physically anythingly i
would never go back there again not for
anyone i am pleased i did it but that
door is now closed and locked engaging
in such an intense physical
transformation for a role is difficult
for any actor while holland may not be
taking on such projects again many other
actors have undergone brutal
transformations for the sake of their
art christian bale for example might be
the star best known for his jaw-dropping
critical transformations he shocked
audiences in the 2004 thriller the
machinist playing an emaciated insomniac
the actor lost 66 pounds for the role
and was fully committed to truly
capturing his character shockingly just
six months after filming wrapped on the
machinist bale had to bulk up to play
bruce wayne in the first of christopher
nolan's batman movies batman begins the
actor quickly gained weight after his
machinist's role so much so that nolan
asked bail to actually lose weight yet
again bale later told train magazine i
gained too much weight in the run-up to
batman begins i wasn't the size that
christopher nolan wanted so i had to cut
down 20 pounds or so just before
shooting i was a lot beefier at first
and this was far from the last time bale
rapidly changed his physique he went
through a similarly rapid transformation
for 2010's the fighter playing a man
addicted to crack cocaine though a
pattern was emerging bale has shared
that he didn't actively seek out such
physically grueling roles he told mtv
news i didn't take this job because i
went oh there's a physical
transformation needed i always go damn
there's a physical transformation needed
tom holland and christian bale are far
from the only actors who have undergone
extreme physical transformations for a
role of course with the likes of matthew
mcconaughey charlize theron and joaquin
phoenix also known for dramatically
changing their appearances to suit a
character of course you've got to admire
these styles for their commitment to
their craft though it's hard to envy
them for the toll it takes on their
bodies and nobody could blame holland
for passing on the chance to do it again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]